so you also have guarantees that your
program will be as efficient as it
possibly can get a few weeks ago I drove
up to the Cambridge computer laboratory
to have a chat with Dr Peter velichkovic
from deepmind Andrea Deke who's a PhD
student at Miele and also Dr Andrew
dudzik who's a research engineer at
deepmind it was a really really fun day
you probably saw I already released one
video from this which was when we did a
leeco challenge at the end of the day
petta showed me around the Cambridge
computer laboratory so that was really
good and I also got to meet one of
peta's professors we did the main
session on algorithmic reasoning and
also a traditional interview so that
will come next but um I just thought I
would release a few little extra bits
that I captured so while I was setting
up at the beginning Peta and Andrew had
a little conversation about category
theories they delved into the
fascinating world of mathematical
structures such as lattices and
groupoids and their relation to category
Theory now category Theory is a branch
of mathematics that deals with abstract
structures their relationships and the
Transformations between them it serves
as a unifying framework for various
mathematical disciplines and has
applications in computer science physics
and even in other fields lattices and
group poets represent different types of
mathematical structures with lattices
being partially ordered sets and
groupoids being algebraic structures
which generalize groups their discussion
highlights how these structures can
appear and interesting from a
categorical perspective but can still
possess intriguing properties when
considering specific cases the
conversation also touched on the concept
of categorification which involves
uplifting problems to higher categorical
levels while acknowledging the value of
working at different levels of
abstraction Peta and Andrew emphasize
the importance of understanding the
problem at hand before attempting to
categorize it and they also expressed a
preference for working with algebra
first to gain a deeper understanding of
the problem before attempting to
generalize and lift it to higher
categorical levels multiple operators
who had to actually take the punch card
programs and like
run them and so on yeah so this was
Rosemary Hill in front of the Ad Sack
which is one of the first historic
program computers that was invented here
in the mathematical lab as it was known
back then and she was one of the
operators whose job it was to assist
users of the machine yeah wow it's the
the world's first webcast this is the
world's first web checking the coffee
coffee room was wow it looks like a a
rack
it's got all of those old RS 2 I would
have said rs232 but it actually says
rs423
2010 deepmind Technologies wow look at
that
on the uh the Hall of Fame of companies
that came out of the Cambridge computer
lab this is one of the oldest versions
of a computer that has access it has
like capabilities built into the
hardware so you can actually exercise
certain levels of secure access to
various parts of memory yeah
play with the different knobs they're
still
operational and ironically airplanes
haven't really Advanced much since then
yeah exactly
they have this very funky prop in here
which is the door to the very first
computer science department that
Cambridge had and as you can see it's
called the mathematical laboratory
rather than the computer laboratory
which it was eventually renamed to at
some point
so this is like a very very cool piece
of History right here
um which shows the beginnings of
computer science research in Cambridge
and another thing that's very cool is
this poster which is right next to the
door which shows some of the earliest
kinds of useful programs that have been
that have been written in this
mathematical laboratory on these like
really large computers that were
invented here in Cambridge and these
particular programs served to help
mathematicians with some really
challenging numerical tasks that they
wouldn't be able to otherwise do I think
in particular some of the codes you have
in there perform numerical integration
which is a very important routine that
mathematicians have to do and it's
certainly not one that they can do
easily by hand so computers were
certainly quite important for that now I
would like to direct your attention to
this pattern on the on the on the glass
behind you which is maybe you wouldn't
expect that maybe it's a detail that
might not immediately come into Focus
but it's actually quite relevant to the
story I just told you do you have any
idea what this pattern might be Tim
um is it Moscow no it's not Morse code
actually although it yeah it does have
like two symbols of different shapes so
it could be but it's not Morse code
actually is it um a punch card for a
Mainframe that is exactly a punch card
and specifically it is the punch card
which implements that exact program for
numerical integration
with lattices but then actually like
almost everything I say is probably true
if you replace the lattices with
categories so in this sense it's like
yeah category Theory
um like anyway
things can be
complicated for different reasons like
lattices are complicated for sort of the
the like orthogonal reason that group
whites are complicated right
um
group weights have none of the
interesting like relational
like aspect to them yeah or like
ordering aspect
but then the set of morphisms itself is
like can be horribly complex right
that's right that's right so basically
what you're saying is like if you look
at a group point from a bird's eye view
it really doesn't look all that
interesting just equivalence classes
basically but like the actual stuff that
goes on in a groupoid can be
particularly interesting right yeah yeah
well it depends on what you're
interested in yes exactly exactly
somehow like everything you're
interested in is this correct this might
be correct like everything of interest
is some combination of like lattices and
groupoids
that should be true potentially yes I'm
liking this interviewer role that I'm
that I'm having right now right yeah oh
this is gold I hope you're getting all
this
okay so basically what you're saying is
that like when you say something is
uninteresting to a category theorist
it's because like when you abstract
things away it doesn't look all that
rich or is that what you're trying to
say uh the thing category stuff well I I
think that there's sometimes
a misunderstanding of where the
interesting part is right I mean I think
I've talked to some people who like only
want to work with categories and then if
something fails to be the most General
possible category it could be that's
automatically uninteresting but in a
more fine-grained sense like if you're
interested in some property and that
property doesn't go away when you pass
to a special case then maybe that
special case is interesting right right
that's right right yeah I guess that's a
good point
um so in in what sense uh would you say
your thesis is interesting and in what
way you would say it's uninteresting
then
um well I think it's interesting in that
it provides sort of a good analysis of
special cases of like General issues of
concern in Doodle categories
um actually there was a funny moment in
the discussion with David the other day
where
um he ended up making this declaration
of basically like that he has achieved
sort of monoidal Enlightenment like that
he's ready he's ready for his
categorical products to not be Cartesian
right uh and so which I said yes but are
you ready for your categorical
co-products to not be co-cartesian
because that's to me that's the real
test of like maturity in this area
um is like
uh because a lot of people working in
minodial categories they're really
they're plus still means plus you know
right it doesn't mean anything
interesting so so I think like um for
understanding some of these issues where
you have like the radically
non-cartesian and non-co-cartesian case
I think my thesis is interesting I see
well given that one of the first things
we do in our paper is we try to redefine
what plus means is that does that make
us interesting uh I I think so
I think we're we're interesting but at
like too low of a homotopia level to
catch much attention but we can we can
increase our our home until we level
Maybe
um I mean the point is integral
transforms are somehow happening in the
category of sets right and then all the
stuff people are actually studying is
happening in the category of categories
yeah so we're like a whole
epic behind
but that but then again doing it that
way makes it easier for us to explain
what we're doing to people who might
know you know the basics of computer
science and sets Theory whereas not
necessarily being super expert in
categorical stuff right so maybe we can
make the jump but we first have to like
gain traction if that makes sense that's
that's right yeah I mean I I would I
would add that there
there's no like working at a higher
categorical level comes with problems
and the biggest problem I see is that
people say oh you shouldn't be working
down there and solving up this problem
down there you should be working up here
but then they don't actually the problem
doesn't lift like the problem that we're
working on doesn't appear in the way
that they've abstracted it right so
they're claiming like we have a more
General view or like a higher level view
but in fact they don't they don't
understand the problem and so it doesn't
appear in their description right so
like I'm all in favor of categorifying
when you know what you want to
categorify but before that I no I I I'm
I want to do algebra you know and then
understand what I have and then maybe be
like oh what if it was a category right
yeah that makes total sense
that was incredible we need to do more
so I think you're better than this being
the seeding this the the work on on GNN
in well in Cambridge
department
and also with the the graph
representation learning course that we
are co-teaching is also training a new
generation of of young scientists from
every part of the world to to do both
theory and practice of of graph
representation learning and I'm very
happy to say that because of better we
we
we can really compete with every body in
this planet
and I will say that my second meeting
with Pietro back when I did not even
want to do any kind of research he
hasn't yet seen any code that I've
written and he said immediately Peter
you should do a PhD like you should you
should not think about all this other
stuff research is for you you should do
a PhD so in many ways Pietro's repeated
convincing is the reason why I ended up
doing a research career the kind of
thing between in Italian
it may work differently for Djokovic and
his Italian friend but with us it works
very very well
actually put this in the episode
and I can tell you from my perspective
petar is world famous
so I just interviewed him at neurops in
in New Orleans a couple of months ago
and I'm following him around
you have graphs everywhere yes and he's
creating graphs
cool thank you so much cheers
okay so yeah I've just finished
recording with petrovalichkovic and
Andrea and Andrew it was a great day
yeah and actually just holding
the the Gimbal and the heavy camera
doing the recording and stuff but um
yeah we finished off with the leeco
challenge which I thought might get a
lot of views and interest but yeah we
spoke all about algorithmic reasoning
and a little bit about categories at the
beginning so um yeah great trip
um I'm up in Cambridge so it's about an
hour and a half's drive away from from
my place
but yeah looking forward to publishing
it cheers